3. Keys to being an effective leader
number one empathy
empathy is the ability to understand
and share the feelings of others.
In Matthew, Jesus says
he did not come to be served,
but to serve others,
and a leader who demonstrates this quality
can connect with their team members on a personal level.
Number 2 A positive attitude.
Attitude determines altitude
and your attitude has a direct impact
on how far you will rise in your church or ministry.
Leaders who have a positive attitude are optimistic
and resilient.
They can inspire their team to be focused
on the vision and persevere through obstacles.
Number 3 A leader must have self discipline.
Self discipline is the ability to control ones impulses,
your emotions and behavior.
It creates a culture of discipline and accountability.
It's been said
everything rises and falls on leadership.
The success or failure of a ministry or church
is directly related to the quality of you
and your leadership.